Hello, I'm Kenneth Branagh
and I'm talking "Belfast" with The Academy.
From this period,
most certainly the movies in the film
are ones that had a big, big impact.
Whether it was because Raquel Welch
in "One Million Years B.C."
was so dazzlingly arresting
or "Chitty Chitty Bang Bang,"
where not only did you have amazing color,
but you had a very unforgettable figure
in the child catcher.
It was those big immersive ones at that time
that took us to epic landscapes.
But on television, that's where the Westerns sat.
"Shane," although that didn't make it into the movie,
was a big influence.
In our villain Billy Clanton,
we have a great actor, Colin Morgan,
who looks a lot like Jack Palance in "Shane"
with the raven black hair
and the, you know, the lean and hungry look.
And and the sound of music, actually
with the late, great Christopher Plummer,
Robert Wise, of course, director
who edited Citizen Kane and Judy Julie
Andrews at the center of it, it was those
big immersive ones
at that time that took us
to sort of epic landscapes.
They they were really
they were really very, very memorable.
But on on, on television,
whether they'd been black and white
or not, I was seeing black and white films
because there was no color then for us.
And that's where the Western SAT
seemed to be, where I saw westerns
and where I saw silent movies, comedy,
particularly Laurel and Hardy,
Max Sennett Pictures,
Buster Keaton, Harold Lloyd, etc.
But a lot of John Ford westerns
like the man who shot Liberty Valance,
which is a later western of his Shane,
although that didn't make it into
the movie, was a big influence.
And though didn't make it into the movie
in our villain Billy Clanton.
We have a great actor, Colin Morgan,
who looks a lot like Jack Palance in shade
with the raven black hair and the,
you know, the lean and hungry look.
But other what I call saturated
Technicolor
Sixties movies that we watched as a family
were things
like the Great Escape.
Hey, I am Inara Talbot,
and I'm with the Academy of Motion
Pictures.
Hi, endora, nice to meet you.
Hi, it's
such a pleasure to get to talk to you.
Thank you.
You know, the academy.
We we know how much,
how much even the love of movies
is part of your film.
And I would just love to know,
are the movies in your films
actually movies
that you watched as a child
that you remember and impacted your life?
Or if there are other movies,
what might those be?
Yeah.
You know, a there's obviously
in the way that you filmed the movie,
you know
this this kind of sixties glamor
with the parents and whatever else is his,
it's a view from his world
how he's seeing his world.
Which I thought was absolutely wonderful.
Do you also have any specific
do you know the first movie that you saw
in a movie theater?
Um, it feels as though it would be
one of the first Beatles films.
I think it would be something like Hard
Day's Night Black and White Richard Lester
63, 64 and beautiful black and white
in that actually and a sort of real,
madcap, absurdist quality to it.
Those early Beatles films had a kind of
anarchic energy to them that was cheeky.
It felt very cheeky and
both in the characters of those Beatles,
but also Richard Lester's style.
And later, I realized that he brought
a lot of people who were from comedy
and from farce into into the
what people like Victor Simonetti
and Eleanor Bron, who were great
figures in British comedy at that time.
So I remember that feeling feeling.
I didn't know that
there was just an energy
that I know my parents are so sweet of you
to say what you just did.
But I guess one couldn't help
but see them as very glamorous
and that they were poor
and black and white, if you like.
But they were part of a sort of energy
and explosion
of energy that we were feeling
in terms of fashion and music.
There was a sort of, yes,
a sort of vibrancy.
Eventually, it spilled over into civil
rights riots in Paris,
other social political events and things.
But I think, as I recall,
that would have been the earliest one
I saw at the Capital Cinema
on the Antrim Road, a walk across
Alexandra Park from our house.
Wow, that is that is truly amazing.
I have to ask this because I, you know,
I am a Shakespeare
fan nerd.
I went to Shakespeare Theater Camp
as a little kid.
How do you do
you find any lessons in Shakespearean
storytelling that you use for
for your big budget movies?
And also, you know, for,
you know, this movie for a belt?
Well, you know, it's
such an interesting question
that you can't help but put sort of rifle
through all of the sort of privilege
you've had to look at the work
of great dramatist.
I think of plays like Julius Caesar
or Coriolanus, where
Shakespeare very strongly characterizes
what he might call.
Some might call the fickleness of the mob
or the the the capacity
for disgruntled citizens to very swiftly
light a blue touch paper of unrest
and for it
to accelerate into a sort of
code red really, really very,
very swiftly and frighteningly indeed.
And then the the
the possibility of being drawn into it.
So I remember talking about this
to Katrina both when and it was
something that did happen in our own
lives.
When, when as a young boys and nine,
ten year old boy,
I did get almost looked
physically caught up in this crowd
that took us to what
became the looting of a supermarket
where I, in some attempt to sort of
bring back some trophy for the family,
decided that a family pack of washing
powder would be the most useful thing.
This did not impress my mother,
who chased me all the way back.
And it really was a tipping point
in our lives when she realized
that, again, what Shakespeare
might call the fickleness of the mob
or the fervent nature of the mob.
There is a tide in the affairs of men,
which taken at the flood
leads on to fortune.
But in this case, ill fortune.
We were suddenly in danger,
and it was one of the moments
where she realized that having been
caught up in that adrenalized excitement
that this looked like a blue touch
paper, we'd
we were we had lost control.
And so with that
at play in the life of our family,
it became a moment where the biggest
and toughest of decisions
had to be made
about protecting ourselves from moments
in the future
that could end up being tragic.
Yes. Wow, what an amazing parallel
I would have seen before.
And this is the very last thing.
Could I just please have you slate
it, just introduce your name and say that
I am talking Belfast at the academy?